i think what i want to get across most
is like yes i'm grieving but i do still
want to talk about my baby
and i think people forget that
people don't want to make you
uncomfortable and they're like oh like
he died so we can't say that and that
word even makes people uncomfortable
people don't like to say like he died
but he did he died
i do have like a lot of nerves right now
yeah like it's all happening right now
it's a day to talk about your whole life
yeah and i want to make sure like
everyone has fun
but i'm also a little nervous just with
everyone being in the same space again
you're gonna be nice yeah
that was a clip of madison hausburg
getting ready for her big day her
wedding which fans will see on the
season finale of siesta key this week
joining us now is the newlywed herself
madison hello hi
how are you doing i'm doing okay
you know we just showed a clip of you
getting ready for your big day you are
so beautiful
you are seven months into
marriage what would you say your
favorite thing is about newlywed life
with your sweet husband uh just like
leaning on each other for the hard stuff
it's been so amazing just having a
partner there what do you remember most
about that day with you two
oh just having our families together
that was huge because they hadn't met
before the wedding wow did it feel like
a full circle moment having the cameras
there because of course your husband-ish
she's a producer on the show and now the
cameras are there to capture the biggest
moment in your love story it's cool
because the camera crew is also it is so
much part of our story and like he knows
all of them like he's worked with that
like he's worked on other shows with
them you know one thing that i love
about your love story is the age gap my
parents my parents are 20 years ago yes
oh my god now do people do people
still have something to say about you
and ish being 20 years apart they do but
but most people have come around okay
most people have come around so
i mean certainly not my friends my
friends are all like oh yeah no this
totally makes sense now
now obviously this season finale is
a joyous episode seeing the wedding but
it is also
very heart-wrenching with you sharing
the story of losing your sweet baby boy
just felt like the whole world just like
stopped
it just was so
unprepared these past five months have
been
such a blur for me um
i don't know it's it's going to be hard
for sure
it'll be tough i know it's a loaded
question but
how are you doing both mentally and also
physically um thank you for asking
it's
it it's been really hard it's been
really hard and i don't feel like people
say you know it'll get easier it doesn't
it doesn't and i've talked to a lot of
lost moms and really other lost moms
have been like have really like saved me
and so i hope to
be able to be that for someone else
i hope someone sees my story and you
know thinks okay i'm not alone where
would you say you are in the grieving
process it's up and down i have good
days and bad days
i think
i think what i want to get across most
is like yes i'm grieving and but i do
still want to talk about my baby
and i think people forget that
people don't want to make you
uncomfortable and they're like oh like
he died so we can't say that and that
word even makes people uncomfortable
people don't like to say like he died
but he did he died and to me that also
means he lived
and so i really like i want to get
across that
just because yes it makes me really sad
talking about elliot it also makes me
really happy like i want to talk about
how cute his nose was like i wanted to
talk about the color of his hair like
every other mom gets to talk about those
things and like those things make me
happy like yes i'm crying but like those
things are also really wonderful things
he's still my son he's still my baby
and how is your husband doing i know he
got a sweet little tattoo
of your baby boy's hand print yeah he
doing in the grieving process he's doing
he's doing really well he's definitely
he's definitely being strong for me
as husband and wife how has that made
your marriage stronger it's made it so
much stronger so much stronger just
seeing the way
he
loves elliot is also the most beautiful
thing because one thing i struggle with
a lot is connecting with elliot
um
now that he's not physically here and
i've seen
ish connect with him in such a beautiful
level that it like inspires me um you
know i do hope to have a living baby
um
but i know that
elliot will always be a part of my life
and he will
he will
affect the way i am a mother in the
future as well
and so i do have hope you know that i
will have
we are trying to have a baby
another baby and so i do have hope that
i i will have that in the future
the trying process
how is that for you
mentally to have to work through that
knowing what's on the other side but
still grieving in the moment that you're
in
it's it's really hard it's really hard
um we got pregnant with elliot our first
try
and it hasn't been the same this time
around
they took us in and
there was no heartbeat
it was
the hardest moment of my life
they handed me him
it was so perfect
so perfect what has the healing process
been like for you physically a lot of
people forget if you don't bring a baby
home people like don't think you're
postpartum you know you don't look like
a mom to the rest of the world when
you're in the grocery store without a
baby
um but it's hard like i have to
like i still you know i gained all the
weight i um i'm losing hair every day in
between
all of those feelings of
the rollercoaster of feelings the
sadness and maybe some anger there
you do still feel hope i do i do those
days when i wake up and take a pregnancy
test it just kind of takes me all back
to when i see the negative
those are really tough days
and there are days when i feel utterly
hopeless
um but
i do i have hope and i think it really
is the lost community that has helped me
through this some wonderful wonderful
support groups and just looking at
elliot's adorable face every day it's
just
it gets me through it the baby lost
community is huge and they are
incredible people they are really
incredible because we've all been
through something that's like
unimaginable
and
it it's been really wonderful i feel
like you know when i heard your story
too it made me think of chrissy teigen
as well and her sharing your story and
yeah and helping break the stigma of
just the conversation around losing a
baby you guys really are helping so many
other people
we're pregnant
and now obviously in this grieving
process
do you know how you're going to approach
siesta key another season
as it right now
i would say i'm very open to talking i'm
in this i'm in this position right now
where i feel the need to talk about
elliott and i don't know that that will
always be the case there may be some
point where i'm like okay
now i just want it to be my story he's
just mine you know i want to keep him to
myself right now um but as of now i've i
really do want to shout it from the
rooftops i want to tell everyone you
know about him i'm very proud of him
that's amazing and you are
such a pillar of strength and we
appreciate your time and and your open
heart sharing your story and i will keep
you and your family and my prayers and
thank you you know we'll be thinking
about you and in the meantime fans can
catch more of madison's story on the
season finale of siesta key when it airs
this thursday
you